are joined now by the labour leader
sakir stama thanks for being with us do
you think
vladimir putin is committing a war crime
here
well he must be held fully to account
and it's clear that we've seen
unprovoked aggression unprovoked
invasion by russia
of a european country and that's why
this is such a serious moment it's why
we must stand resolutely and firmly with
ukraine it's why we must stand united
with our nato allies other allies and
why here in the united kingdom our
political parties must stand united as
well and that is why
we have been very clear as the labour
party the official opposition um that we
support that united stand um you know in
supporting ukraine that we are
unshakable uh in our supporter of nato
it's very important because putin wants
to see
nato and our allies divided putin wants
to see political parties in the united
kingdom and elsewhere divided and we are
not going to be divided
but the reality is that a free
independent democratic country in the
middle of europe is about to be overrun
or we assume
that the russian forces the strength of
the russian forces will prevail about to
be overrun by
an autocratic dictatorship
uh and that is um
that invasion is going on the ukrainian
uh military and army are fighting uh
courageously the people of ukraine are
showing incredible courage we must put
in the strongest possible support united
with our allies and that's why although
i didn't think the sanctions that the
that our government put forward earlier
in the week was strong enough a stronger
package has gone in now
yesterday i've indicated that we the
labour party will support that i want to
see the government go even further
than that but
in the past we have not been strong
enough in response to putin that has
given him the idea that um you know the
benefits of his aggression outweigh the
costs and we cannot allow that to happen
again the package we put in now must be
enough not just to isolate russia but to
[ __ ]
its ability to function
you say in the past we haven't been
strong enough uh with putin isn't the
problem here that you supported a
a labor leader who actually wanted a
weaker nato not a stronger nato
the labour party um you know was there
at the founding of uh nato bevin um you
know
then the secretary of state labour
secretary of state signed the treaty
that i saw for myself
in brussels when i visited nato
headquarters two weeks ago to express
our unshakable support for nato so labor
support of nato has been there from the
very very beginning and even in the last
five years we've mentioned jeremy corbyn
jeremy corbyn sorry to interrupt but
jeremy corbyn wanted to stop the
expansion of nato and as i say you were
supporting him as as leader
well let me be very clear the labour
party um has never wavered in its
support of nato our policy has never
changed jeremy corbyn was wrong about
that but the labour party policy never
shifted under his leadership and i've
been very clear that's why i went to
brussels to meet the secretary general
just two weeks ago
to express our
support for the action in relation to
ukraine but also to send a wider message
in relation to the labour party that
true to our history our traditions and
to the signing of the treaty in the
first place our support for nato is
unshakable
and what do you make of
what putin is doing here um you know
i've just been speaking to ben wallace
who says that the man is clearly not
acting rationally um or logically do you
agree with that
well um
very hard for any of us to
you know express uh clear views on
what's going on in putin's head i do
think that the failure the collective
failure
of um you know the west if you like in
relation to action he's taken in the
past so many examples georgia crimea
donbass have given him the sense that as
i say the benefits of his aggression
outweigh the costs we have to be clear
that that isn't the case here in
relation to ukraine and that that
package the response package um from the
rest of the world will be so strong
that it will not only isolate
russia but also
triple its ability to function
right and just to be clear on sanctions
you think
we should be going further uh in regards
for instance to the swift uh banking the
payment system the swift banking payment
system further measures in relation to
sovereign debt in russia and very
importantly further measures here in the
uk in relation to
shell companies
that are backing russia that are there
as depositories for russian money we
have to break those companies open
that's going to require legislation we
should have done this years ago frankly
it's going to require legislation
i indicated in parliament yesterday
that if that legislation is brought
forward and it could be brought forward
on monday we will support it it could go
through
the house of commons very very quickly
because
there is no dispute here that we need to
take this this action
well there is dispute it doesn't seem
like the eu or the united states want to
want to do that
well
we need to persuade our allies to take
this step and we the united kingdom need
to take a lead in it in relation to
swift that action needs to be taken
in relation to russian sovereign debt
but in relation to the shell companies
here in the united kingdom we in the
united kingdom can take the action um to
break open and get behind these shell
companies look at the real beneficiaries
and take appropriate action where
there's any connection any support with
putin and his regime
thanks for being with us this morning